I heard that you met your girl on
Instagram I did Chris cos that could go
real south I'm just saying here's what I
did though
here's what I did because I knew it
could go south okay cuz it's it's online
dating I mean yeah and you're famous yes
the position I was in uh it's tough to
meet people I don't get to go out a
whole lot so I was like you know what
I'll do on Vyra to show and if she sucks
I can just air is weird I can just go
have fun at the show and then Security's
their gates are there three months it's
a crazy break three months and we've
been married for 11 years
[Applause]
wait get married you let me see the ugly
side that's what I said she was like
we'll figure it out when we get me ask
you to do holidays when I was three
monster is it nope no Wow I met her
father and he said well if she'll have
you you can I did the right thing I
won't talk to her father and he was like
well she'll have you okay that's a
blessing I guess I guess you're fine
Zoey I also this is hilarious I hear you
have it's not clearance it's awesome
I have a girl crush on her as well but
you love Reba McEntire yes there we are
that's the vow is that's like one of the
coolest knots in my life that's me
getting inducted into the Grand Ole Opry
family who's gonna come out and do the
official induction and freaking Reba
McEntire she's so lovely did you have a
weird object in my basement that Oh all
my friends that come over they haven't
been there yet I'm so excited about
what's about to come out of your mouth
you have a weird object in your basement
yeah okay
so I did a trophy case from that night
with Reba from the ground will operate
yeah and it's that trophy and then
there's this tissue paper that's there
and people are like what is that and so
we started crying she was saying such
sweet and important things to me I
started bawling onstage and then she
goes and to sing his first song is the
grand old off remember his dust notes
and I'm like just a mess crying onstage
and she ran offstage drags me tissues
and then runs back onstage and hands me
tissues so that's my weird object tissue
that is weird you planned on studying
medicine which is amazing you got
accepted middle school you're gonna go
hey here take that news not great yeah I
mean is I promised my parents I'll
graduate and when I got to college I
fell in love with how the human body
works so it's kind of a natural
progression to get to med school but
then I just had this what-if down inside
and and I was like I got to chase this
dream I have to try it you know if it
doesn't work out fine but I went and
told my parents that I would be putting
off med school to go and play for tips
in a jar at a honky-tonk every parent's
dream my dad backed me up to the wall in
the hallway pretty quick that's a
southern daddy here is the best part
though so I hear the only
you ever received in high school was
music after your parents knowing that
did it make it harder that's probably
what they were leaning on yeah but
honestly at that point I'd been playing
in a lot of bars and frat parties a lot
of college events around the southeast
yeah so I think they were like a little
bit confused yeah so they gave me their
blessing and yeah you gotta follow your
dream you want baby honestly dad Ben I
thought he's gonna punch me in the
throat the first whenever I told him but
yeah he was the first guy to be driving
us to and from gigs and helping us set
up right after that's so cool doing your
tears the tissue show the tissue all the
time to your family so we've been asking
everybody what their campaign slogan
would be your presidential campaign
slogan since it's your name it's the
year you want to run and it's your last
text okay I know what it is actually
Dustin let's 20:48 drink drink drink
[Applause]
it's so dumb I'm so competitive - so
long I don't remember is like something
I was apologizing cuz that I returned
some text and I'm still long-winded
about it yeah grimace face in the face I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this